iniziamo con una domanda
come nasce una
quando un granello di sabbia si insinua
all'interno dell'ostrica l'ostrica
genera una secrezione che si avvolge
tutti intorno al granello di sabbia e
con il tempo lo trasforma in una perla e
ha pensato quale migliore metafora della
resilienza di questo cioè il fatto di
trasformare un problema non risolverlo
trasformare un problema in una risorsa
ed è una cosa che noi abbiamo insita fin
da bambini
vi ricordate prima di iniziare a
camminare quante volte siamo caduti per
riuscire a camminare e siamo caduti
siamo rialzati siamo caduti siamo
rialzati e ogni volta che credevamo
imparavamo un modo in cui non mettere il
piede poi dopo siamo nati per esclusione
e siamo arrivati a stare in piedi e
rimanere in equilibrio per sempre a voi
vi immaginate se le persone iniziassero
a camminare in età adulta figurate velo
ci sarebbe gente che al secondo
tentativo smetterebbe se no guarda non è
non fa per me non è nelle mie skills
stare in equilibrio
andate avanti voi che ci sarebbero le
città piene di persone che camminano
così quando si dice guarda bene la
strada quando attraversi no ma mi sono
chiesto ma perché da adulti è tutto così
difficile è invece quando siamo bambini
risulta tutto facile perché da adulti
siamo mossi più dalla paura
dell'insuccesso che dal piacere del
successo ed è una cosa anacronistica
perché se pensiamo alle vite dei grandi
personaggi sono costellate da fallimenti
per arrivare nella loro isoletta del
dell'auto
realizzazione ha dovuto attraversare
foreste di fallimenti
no aspetta un attimo per capirla anch'io
questa perché però mi piaceva questa no
pensiamo veramente ai grandi personaggi
la storia
pensiamo ai anne rowling michael jordan
charlie chaplin van gogh steve jobs
loro hanno fondato il loro successo sui
pilastri del fallimento è una cosa
incredibile
già già già alcuni ecco questo questo ci
indica quanto lavoro ci sia
prima di arrivare al successo questo è
quello che magari per qualcuno può
essere il fallimento invece questa è la
resilienza che ti permette di arrivare a
questo vale lui no lui fece tesoro ha
fatto voleva entrare voleva andare a
lavorare a facebook
l'hanno mandato via niente no lo
compriamo ciclope di hera e basta
è lui è lui invece si è fatto sulle mani
chi ne ha continuato a lavorare da solo
o resilienza e ha inventato whatsapp e
l'ha venduto a facebook per 12 miliardi
di dollari
thomas edison l'inventore della
lampadina che poi non la inventò lui la
perfezione fece 2000 tentativi 2000
prima di riuscire a indovinare il giusto
equilibrio tra filo gas spessore del
bulbo della lampadina 2000 tentativi per
2.000 volte si è messo lì a provare poi
c'è riuscito hanno fatto una conferenza
stampa siano i giornalisti funziona
visto gli disse sento il signor edison è
vero che lei ha fallito 1999 volte e lui
disse io non ho fallito 1999 volte io ho
scopo
certo 1999 modi in cui non si fa una
lampadina e io ho pensato questa è una
frase che ci dovremmo tatuare nella
mente io ho scoperto 1999 modi in cui
non si fa una lampadina cielo dovremmo
attuare nella mente soprattutto in
quest'epoca del del tutto e subito del
take away in quest'epoca dove sembra che
lo sport nazionale sia ottenere il
massimo con il minimo sforzo
in quest'epoca in cui digitiamo prima di
pensare
fotografiamo prima di guardare
giudichiamo prima di capire in questa
epoca dove la pubblicità ci insegna che
possiamo ottenere tutto proprio senza
fatica ecco tutte le cose che puoi fare
col minimo sforzo e noi la nostra umile
mente un po alla volta si lascia
condizionare
se pensiamo che effettivamente sia così
ma non è così perché non è possibile
cadere non è scusate non è possibile
camminare senza prima avere essere
caduti molte volte è una cosa innegabile
è una cosa soprattutto che dovremmo
portare alla luce un concetto che
dovremmo riesumare per i nostri per i
nostri figli perché adesso li tuteliamo
abbiamo paura che cadano perché non ci
facciano mai quando vanno quando
prendono un brutto voto a scuola
picchiamo il professore li bocciano
facevo cambiare scuola li promuovano
picchiamo la scuola e cosa capisce il
ragazzino di questo che la vita è facile
no
la vita non è facile la vita è fatta di
fallimenti
il mio è un elogio al fallimento devono
sbagliare anche i bambini per cadere e
farsi la loro piccola crosticina
indispensabile per poi affrontare i
problemi più grossi
io mi ricordo quando ero piccolo
voi sapete che non si può uscire da qua
prendiamo la scossa e io mi ricordo
quando ero piccolo anche da qua
anche la qua allora mia madre mi regolo
una bicicletta
ovviamente questa è una cosa che è
successa molti di voi per la mia vita
nuova e io ogni volta che tornavo a casa
da scuola con la bicicletta c'era un
gruppo di bulletti che me la buttavano a
terra e ci saltano sopra e io ogni volta
che uscivo da scuola cerchiamo una via
diversa per evitare questi bulletti
certe volte andavo facevo il giro largo
andavano i sentieri perché un giorno ne
parlai con mia madre e mia madre mi
disse non funziona così deve affrontare
le tue paure
magari uscirne sconfitto ma devi
affrontare le tue paure e allora un
giorno un bel giorno ho preso la via
bicicletta e sono andato in direzione di
casa tranquillo ho trovato i bulletti
sono fermati davanti a me preso il
coraggio gli umani ha detto avete
problemi con la mia bicicletta
beh sono rimasto stupito dalla reazione
perché non sapevano cosa dire erano
bloccati perché non se lo aspettavano
non se lo aspettavano ed è stata una
cosa straordinaria
poi vabbè dopo hanno preso la bicicletta
me l'ha buttata per terra ci sono
saltati sopra ea quel punto per non
farli sentire a disagio
ho dato due colpi anch'io ma il concetto
è che il concetto che quella situazione
mi ha fatto crescere la mia piccola
crosticina la mia piccola crosticina che
io chiamo esperienza sulla quale poi
dopo affondato tutto tutte e tutti gli
altri fallimenti insomma come ben sanno
i giapponesi i giapponesi hanno
inventato l'arte keane su g
eccola qua cosa significa loro quando
rompono un vaso non è che lo buttano
loro lo aggiustano con dei filamenti di
oro ed argento e questo significa che il
vaso da rotto acquista più valore ancora
del vaso da giu stato e questo è
il valore dell'esperienza ed è un
insegnamento straordinario e ora però io
io che non sono giapponese ok
come posso fare ecco io credo che a
questo punto sia importante riprendere
il concetto di giovanni pascoli che nel
1897 teorizzò l'esistenza di un
fanciullo dentro di noi è un concetto
che riprese da platone di un fanciullo
che c'è dentro di noi un fanciullo che è
importante che rimanga dentro di noi che
non cresce con noi non cresce con noi
rimane dentro piccolino però è quel
fanciullo che ci aiuta a vedere la
poesia nelle cose
ecco io credo che più che mai in
quest'epoca sia indispensabile
ricollegarsi a quel fanciullo farlo
vivere perché quel fanciullo quel
bambino che è dentro di noi e quello che
non ha paura a cadere che non ho paura
delle cose più grosse e quel bambino che
ci aiuta a vedere le cose con il sorriso
è quel bambino tra l'altro che nel
nostro corpo occupa uno spazio
piccolissimo lo spaccio di un granello
di sabbia
però se ne abbiamo cura quel piccolo
bambino può trasformare la nostra vita
in una perla
[Applauso]